نحن الان في بلده نيكوبول في مقاطعه ديني
برو وهذه هي اقرب البلدات الى محطه
للطاقه النوويه الواقعه في
مقاطعه والتي لا يفصلها الا النهر عن
المحطه هذه
[موسيقى]
الاسابيع الماضيه بعد تصاعد الحديث على
احتمال قيام القوات الروسيه وفقا لروايه
الاوكرانيه
بعمل وصفته بالارهابي في هذه المحطه قد
يؤدي الى كارثه نوويه وعلى اساسه ساعدت
السلطات في
اجلائي من اراد الخروج من هذه المدينه كما
تشاهدون هذه المساحات من الاراضي لم تكن
ظاهره قبل تفجيره سد كخوفك قبل عده اسابيع
تفجير السد ساعد اولا على ارتفاع مستوى
النار ثم عاد الحصار مره اخرى لتبدو هذه
هذه المسطحات هذه المساحات من الاراضي
اخيرا السلطات تحذر من الاقتراب من شاطئ
النهر لانها كما تقول ان الجيش الروسي
يعتبر كل من يقترب من النهر هدفا مشروعا
لها ذلك ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت في
اكثر في اكثر من مناسب او اكثر من مره ان
تقوم بعمليات خاصه
النهر والوصول الى تلك المحطه ولكن لم
يكتب لتلك المحاولات اي نجاح عمر الحاجه
الجزيره من بلده نيكوبول